most of the world doesn't care about
wanting to fully found the secrets about
business and life and entrepreneurship
they want to be entertained your best
friend and accumulating wealth is
momentum don't get in the way of
momentum that friend of yours that's
always spreading gossip to you about
everybody's personal life you got to
stop picking up her calls need
motivation watch a top ten on believe
nation what's that believe nation it's
Evan I believe in you and this channel
is designed to be part of your daily
success routine so let's get your
motivation to attend and get you
believing in you grab a snack and chew
in today's lessons from my main who went
from immigrating to the United States
from arraign as a ten-year-old during
the Iranian Revolution to serving in a
US military to then starting the PHP
agency' and the value tainment brand
whose mission is to inspire millions of
people around the world
he's Patrick by David and here's my take
on his top 50 rules for success
okay let's kick it off with rule number
one pursue your dreams man what happened
to pops when he started a business he
failed
what happened to mom and dad they got a
divorce what happened to us we have six
different places was it fun hell no it
wasn't fun what happened in high school
to you did you play baseball did you
play highschool basketball
did you get picked off for football did
you date to grow your life what was your
GPA who were you in high school
who are you afterwards what makes you
think you're gonna make it in life now
you got to stop selling this stuff to
this guy man stop it it's getting old go
get that job that you let go of pain you
12 bucks an hour and part-time get a
degree stop taking these damn risks
we're not meant to do something big with
our lives
simple as that are we done
[Music]
I'm done I'm good okay good
hey I want you to know this voice is
never going away this voice is always
going to be there no matter how much
money you're going to make it's always
going to be there the great thing about
it is though every morning you wake up
you have a choice on which voice to
listen to but I want you to think about
a completely different thing right now
let's just say you do nothing but you
say you buy into your fears but you say
you buy into every single thing you're
worried about let's just say you don't
make any decisions to go after your
dreams faster over ten years from that
20 years from now 30 years from now 40
years from now but you say your funerals
around a corner
you have 50 people there hundred people
there maybe 200 people show up these
your friends family and people that love
you should be left for one generation
remembered for two generations and
forgotten after that it's a truly the
life you want to live is that really
what you want to do I don't know if
that's the life you really want to live
you see what I've noticed is no matter
what you ever do you'll have a lot of
lonely times we can lie to your family
you can lie to your friends you can fold
the world into realizing that why you
didn't win was because of some challenge
that you have to face but there's one
person you can never lie to and that is
the man in the mirror you can never lie
to the man in the mirror never for the
rest of your life the man in the mirror
is going to look back at you and say you
did not choose to go after your dreams
and you have to be okay with that now
what I would like to encourage you to do
is to make the right choice I encourage
you to face your fears and pursue your
dreams
go pursue the dreams that matter the
most to you you only got one shot at the
stake here and if it works out and it's
gonna feel so good for you and if it
doesn't at least you have the courage to
make that decision hope you make the
right choice I trust you will rule
number two read people let me tell you
one thing that you know most
millionaires master is reading people
greeting people and I'll and I'll tell
you what I mean by reading people okay
the reason why reading people
millionaires end up generally becoming
good at reading people is because
they've been ripped off backstabbed
alights who cheated so many times that
there are a lot of signals that they see
a trend that saying this person's like
that reminds me of this person you gotta
learn how to read people you gotta learn
how to read a customer you gotta learn
how to read an employee you got to learn
how to read someone who is absolutely
full of it sometimes I get surprised how
some people who are pretty successful
they're making 100 200 300 thousand
dollars a year how easily they fall for
the trap of somebody who's full of it
like how do you not read that sometimes
right you gotta learn how to read it and
in a certain level of paranoia when
you're reading people and then also when
I'm saying reading people it's not just
on a negative side reading people on
someone that's truly you did something
wrong and you need to go out there and
do something about it you need to read
people that need you to make a right
effort to take care of them you don't
make the right effort to you know treat
them in a way that they need to be
treated that's also reading people
another one is when I say reading people
is being able to think what a customer
is going to need now what the customer's
gonna need a year from that three years
from now five years from now and reading
them being able to read a person that
starts with your company at an early
stage and what were they thinking about
when they were at your level at a new
level you're not speaking to them from
your level millionaires they gotta learn
how to read somebody at that level and
give them the belief that they need at
that level versus somebody that's been
around a little longer that needs to
kind of man up or woman up or mature as
an entrepreneur and they're not they're
just treating this as a lollygagging
with the industry that's a complete
different conversation with that person
say grow up already you've been
this thing four five ten fifteen years
what's next you're gonna be like this
your entire life so reading to know when
where who what when they eventually
become very good at reading people rule
number three leverage your time I like
shining shoes I like ironing clothes I
like doing those types of things and I
remember one time one of my mentors said
you know do you want to make $10 an hour
I said no he says then why do you keep
doing $10 an hour jobs I said what do
you mean he said you keep shining shoes
you keep doing this you keep liking
those types of things you got to get
somebody else to help you out so what
happened
I went 100 percent dry cleaners even
when I couldn't afford it I was broke I
went 100 percent dry cleaners
I went 100 percent somebody else helping
me shine my shoes and I gave money to a
business I got an assistant to do my
paperwork for me to do the filing for me
to do all of those things for me to drop
my car off at Jiffy Lube to get an oil
change to get a car wash literally all
of those activities were done by
somebody else and it became a matchup
system to me I had somebody do those
things for me where Allah allowed me to
do the other things even housecleaning
it was somebody else doing it where it's
not me doing it now why is that
important to do you got to get an
assistant so you can leverage your time
do not let $10 an hour job get you out
of business where you end up going back
and getting a job that pays only $10 an
hour focus on what grows your business
rule number four don't change yourself I
got a call from one of my friends from
many many many years ago growing up and
he said you know he's been trying to get
into a relationship and he says path
he's an entrepreneur he says Pat I'm
dating the scroll and you know I'm at a
point right now where I feel like I need
to settle down come on my mid-thirties
said okay he says but she she told me
this I said what'd she say she says it's
either me or the business because she
can't stand the fact that I'm working
the way I am and I'm running a business
and I said what's your answer says well
I don't know what do you think I should
do so I'm not gonna give you my advice
I said what's how are you wired yourself
this is Pat I don't think I can really
do this I said why do you think he says
because you're asking me to change
myself you see
when somebody says it's either me or the
business
let me explain to how an entrepreneur
sees that so maybe it'll help understand
the entrepreneur says it's either your
arm or me what's more important Europe I
love you but I'm not gonna cut my arm
off or you're telling me to be a whole
different human being to be with you
we're now living in biblical times
I'm not gonna cut my arm off for you if
you want me this is me this is how I
come do you like it you don't like it go
find somebody else but this is how I'm
wired I've been like this for 22 years
I've been like this for 38 years it
doesn't mean I'm not gonna change and
improve myself with maturity I am but
I'm an entrepreneur I'm in the hunt I'm
going after it I want to build something
special and significant for my life and
I want to build it with you but not if
you're trying to change me so on the
other side somebody may say well they
spend more time with the business they
love me they love the business more than
they love me no it's how they are
it's how they are it's how they're wired
it's somebody says you know oh oh babe
I'm pregnant what do you me to do when
you're pregnant you go through this a
man may feel like but what's so
important you the baby or me what are
you talking about it's a Sumant you know
we don't understand when the first
pregnancy we're on our third one that's
and I get a grasp understanding of it so
goes who's more important me or the baby
I'm your husband that's that's an
ultimatum
you don't put a mother in a position
like that you don't put an entrepeneur
on the physicians who say to the
business or me they'll typically take
them as who they are for human being
because the last thing you want is date
somebody and then 10 20 years later that
resentment then it can lead to worse
things you had somebody that decided to
change their own DNA to be with you all
because of you you have a delay time
bomb of someone that could eventually
become your biggest enemy in your life
because you try to change them I don't
recommend that one of the best
recommendations I got before I got
married I was dating a girl at one point
and I went to one of my mentors one of
my pastors and I said hey this is this
is what I'm experiencing what do you
think
so does it bother you a lot he said can
you deal without it I said no I cannot I
can't deal with this and he said it's
just gonna give him more so if he can't
deal with the doubt don't think it's
gonna disappear and I have to make that
decision and move on it wasn't easy it
was very difficult because you know I
really care for this human being but I
have to move on so if somebody's really
trying to change somebody and you're an
entrepreneur if the person does change
it's just a matter of time till the
person goes back to being true to who
they are you're gonna be true back to
your the entrepreneur the real
entrepreneur is gonna go back being true
to themselves rule number five have the
right attitude as a young kid just an
knucklehead who thought he knew
everything you know 21 years old I would
have been so annoyed coaching myself at
that time cuz I thought I knew
everything and then the best thing that
ever happened to me the best thing that
ever happened to me is I hit rock bottom
by far the best thing that ever happened
to me is hitting rock bottom I think I
think for men I have two boys and I'm
gonna be in pain when I witnessed these
guys go through this but I think the
best thing that can happen to a man is a
heartbreak a very strong heartbreak and
a very big failure early on in business
and it happened to me early on a life
both heartbreak and business that
happened early on because I thought I
knew it all and it was a slap in the
face to save Socrates says the only
thing I know is that I know nothing if
the greatest minds on their deathbed are
saying things like that what makes you
and I think we know everything quite
frankly everything I'm saying on value
Tim and may be inaccurate
every single thing I'm saying on and
value Timmy you may come back and my
opinions may be wrong it's work for me
this is how it's work for me for me it's
more about teaching how to think and
actually what to think I want to get an
entrepreneur to learn how to think than
what to think but we don't know
everything we got to learn how to adjust
we got to learn how to adapt we got to
learn how to get better we all learn how
to improve and so the mindset of
thinking you know it all and all the
cost it's just it's not a place you want
to be because it means advancements
doesn't come around the corner
and I had the know-it-all attitude at a
young age and it almost cost me there's
a benefit to that there's a benefit
because you become as you push the
envelope a little bit but there's also
the
the leveling off to know that maybe you
don't really know this and let me ask in
question somebody I respect to give me
proper direction that I trust that maybe
they can challenge my position an
opinion but it's good that I have the
audacity so I like it the fact that
there's audacity that you're pushing the
envelope but there's got to be coach
ability and learn ability that you want
to learn in advance as well it doesn't
matter who you are everyone's got to
have somebody that they have a mentor
that's giving them direction with so
it's good that I got out of there pretty
quickly rule number six retain energy
and stamina energy and stamina it
requires energy and stamina to retain
information so if your body is gaining
too much weight and you're tired your
body doesn't have the energy and the
stamina to retain that information to
retain information requires your body to
have the energy to retain it if it
doesn't have it it's not going to retain
it come on Pat you're telling me my
weight has to do with retaining
information yes it does yes it does
because retaining information requires
an effort and anytime you need to take
an effort to do anything it's gonna
deplete what energy and if you don't
have the energy in your mind it just
says I don't have any interest to want
to retain this information because I'm
tired and I don't have stamina and my
energy is low that's why energy is a
very very important game and it's not
just about money energy is not just
about looks and looking pretty and
looking this and exercising because I
want to look at exercising when were
younger was a four-hole different
purpose when you're married with kids
and later on you're an adult you're
exercising for a whole different reason
focus energy stamina sharper mind rule
number seven learn how to sell yourself
selling is something you'll always do
the rest of your life most people don't
like selling some people like to kind of
make it nice and some use a better word
and say communication or just its sales
by the way those that just turn off the
video and don't want to watch about what
selling has to do hey you want to marry
that girl you love
you know which one I'm talking about you
need to sell her and her parents and her
best friend that's all selling you want
to get that promotion purely selling
baby and those who get that promotion
sell better than you do
that's why it is they don't sell a car
their job could be human resource or
something but they learn how to sell
themselves as that position more than
you maybe you ought to learn how to do
it it'll benefit you make you a lot of
money rule number eight copy genius
Picasso once said good artists copy
great artists steal this is one of Steve
Jobs favorite quotes and Steve Jobs once
said we have always been shameless about
stealing great ideas so wait a minute is
it a good or bad thing to steal great
ideas and being a great copycat cuz I
hear some people say sometimes you know
that guy copied my idea that was my idea
I came up with this listen worry when
nobody's copying what you're doing
because no one's paying attention to you
it is a very very very big compliment
when somebody copies rule number nine
why not you
that's the question when you're thinking
big why not you and answer it I'm not
just doing this motivational video why
not you
why shouldn't you win no no forget
motivational let's get logical why not
you actually answer that
why can't you be somebody that can do
something in your business that's never
been done before why don't you answer it
so give the argument bow logically
here's why not me because I don't work
hard enough you can fix that stop being
lazy well whatever but because I'm not
that good of self you can learn sales so
okay because I don't know much about the
product you kill hoarding the products
but why don't you because no one of my
family's been rich so what no one was
enriched and Zuckerberg family before he
became who he is today and nobody was in
jobs jobs mom even gave them up or
adoption yes you know step fine you know
so whatever but so why not you make the
argument why don't you truly get into it
then give the other argument why not you
actually doing this
why shouldn't you to beat why shouldn't
you be the person and say I'm a very
smart person I love people I actually
like to make money to make a difference
in the world and you know what I care
for people and I have some things I want
to do if I get money in my pocket it
would be good I'll do good with it and
I've got a big heart and I am talented
and I thought that that then I know the
right people
boom that's why that's you make both
cases as if you're an attorney
representing yourself one why not you
meaning you shouldn't be the person and
the other why not you meaning you should
be the person sell both of them and I
see which argument wins some tells me
the argument on this sides gonna win
well make that argument
take a sheet of paper make that argument
why not you question that a little bit
who commits you can't do it who
convinced you can be part of a group of
people I want so many guys on the
YouTube that you know are even some of
these guys are considered experts by big
magazines and they've written or your
time bestsellers and they say some [ __ ]
like oh you know entrepreneurs are born
give me a damn break entrepreneurship
can be taught entrepreneurship is an
inspiration that comes from here for
some people that want to solve a bigger
problem
what do you mean entrepreneurship is
something you're born but I completely
disagree with that statement fully
disagree with that statement jump in 48
inches that's not given ability you
can't do that entrepreneurship it is a
formula if you hang around other people
that think like this and you watch this
video and you watch all our value
tainment or some of the people that are
feeding the right type of content you
and the right books you read your
imagination won't stop working because
the entrepreneur is numbers solving
problems how can I do it better faster
why can't you learn those doubts get
skills and the skill sets why can't you
you can so why not you and don't let
anybody convince you that people who
solve some big prompts and you know our
big thinkers they have to be born baby a
big thing I'm here to tell you you can
figure out the formula to thinking
bigger
don't let them convince you that that
these elite people sometimes I sit
around my friends who are worth money as
well I'm around these guys all the time
so now you know hey path you know
Rhonda meeting we're gonna go have some
party with these billionaires oh we're
gonna go and go okay great I'm with
these guys then you know it was always
special because from oh my gosh stop it
already when you almost lost everything
you did not think you were special none
of us do and we you know have our break
and we win you can do this wall rule
number 10 show up every day most people
only pay attention to the final product
of a successful entrepreneur they say
things like I can never be like them or
they got lucky but most don't see is
what they've overcome
all the struggles the daily rejections
the heartaches the betrayals the rumors
with the criticism the empty bank
account and all those lonely nights
while trying to make their vision a
reality you see the only difference
between the one who quits and the one
who doesn't is that they showed up every
day
they worked hard every day they hustled
every day
they learn from a proven mentor every
day they improve every day
they did all this even though they felt
like quitting everyday and eventually
they became who they are today
[Music]
rule number 11 stick to the fundamentals
see when I first got started to business
I was all into listening to all these
motivational tapes listen I got a hold
of every single one of them and I
listened to him over and over and over
and over and I was just so motive
amiable I wanted to motivate everybody
motive a motive oh I'm like Tamil you
know it was all I want to motivate every
single person I come across and then
finally got to a point where I said pad
one if you all you do is motivate
somebody they walk away excited and they
don't do anything about it what are you
really motivating people for for your
own self-satisfaction so people say oh
my gosh what a great mess message you
just gave you such an amazing
motivational speaker I cannot believe
you speak that way then it came to a
point where I'm matured as a person that
I no longer needed the attention for
people to say Pat you're amazing don't
get me wrong I love getting recognition
for my kids
I love getting recognition for my wife
for my family for my blood and from the
people I work with on a daily basis I
love that but to get it for validation
eventually got to portal I said I got to
figure out a way to learn the
fundamentals of business and you know
what happened I was disappointed let me
tell you why I was disappointed when I
seek to find out what are the
fundamentals of what these massively
successful people that was 22 23 years
old you know what it was they master all
the boring stuff that none of these
motivational speakers talked about on
these videos they don't you know why
because who the hell wants to know about
boring stuff what what video that talks
about boring stuff is really going to go
viral it's not gonna go far watch this
video today look how many views it gets
let's look at the commentary of this
video this is not gonna be great video
that's gonna go viral you know why
because it's boring you're waiting for a
secret you're waiting for me to give you
some massive special significant thing
that I'm gonna tell you that's gonna
change your life this week no no it's
what I what what I challenge you to do
last week which is write out your
commitments
and follow through with it can you do
that for 60 months can you do that for
60 months you can you do it for 60
months because I like guarantees in life
and you know what I know about
guarantees if you stick to the basic
fundamentals and constantly improve
adjust adapt but stick to that same
activity over and over and over and over
and over again for 60 straight months
you're bound to dominate your industry
and if you do for 10 years the industry
is gonna know about you you do it for 20
years the world's definitely gonna know
about you by the way nowadays you don't
need 20 years you need three to five
years nowadays but you do need to show
up and do the boring thing every single
there was the boring thing show up on
time early in the morning leave late
improve outreach bizdev collaborate sell
communicate challenge drive lead
technology track and accountability
these are boring things you got to do on
a daily basis but it is what it is rule
number 12 decide to be great do you
think rich people are special you think
people who are very wealthy became very
wealthy because they are just so much
more special than you are it's one of
the biggest misconceptions in the world
they became rich because at some point
they said I think I can do something
with my life I'm sick of it
I figured out certain talents of mine I
don't like this thing my life sucks
I want changes and they changed very
simple you can do that as well rule
number 13 compressed timeframes in 1997
Ferrari 301 went 0 to 16 8.1 seconds
which today 8.1 seconds is a lifetime
but in 1977 super fast then a 1997
Ferrari 456 went zero to sixty four
point nine seconds ok that's almost 25
seconds faster than a Ferrari not 2017
488 the gtp goes zero to 60 in 2.9
seconds super fast now if you
get that trend we went from eight one
four nine to nine so let me ask you
let's go to twenty thirty seven what do
you think of Ferraris gonna be doing at
twenty thirty seven you think it's gonna
do is zero to sixteen point nine seconds
can you imagine point nine seconds you
may say there's no way in the world
here's point nine seconds ready set go
you just won 60 that's point nine
seconds that someone back at eight point
one set four point not is impossible
someone at four point nine so two point
nine is impossible and someone today at
two point nine said point nine is
impossible but what's the point with
this this is an entrepreneur channel
what point am i trying to make is it's a
Ferrari endorsement that I'm making that
at all this two points you the point is
everything in your business today and
the processes that you have whatever it
is from selling from point of context to
sales from receiving the sale to
processing the business to delivering
the business to following up with the
client to hiring firing training
whatever process you have that's tied to
a timeline what can you do to compress
time frames meaning what can you do to
go from doing in a week to doing it in
three days to getting done in the day
what can you do to get it from 24 hours
to 12 hours to 6 hours to 3 hours what
is it what areas of your business can
you completely compress time frames in
today take a sheet of paper make a list
ask what can I do to make the process
faster and don't say it's impossible
then get a committee and ask them to put
input what can we do to make this thing
faster once you do make it faster let me
put it to you this way however fast your
business is growing today it's not even
close to how fast your business can grow
if you figure out ways to compress time
frames in every aspect of your business
that is tied to process or timing you
will be shell-shocked by the results you
start getting with your business once
you're able to figure out a way to
compress time frames
rule number 14 go above and beyond in a
world of business there are two
different types of context you'll make
here's what I mean by it there's a types
of context you'll make that'll give you
referrals that'll give you a good sale
good opportunity you'll be giving a good
referral maybe you'll make 600 bucks on
a sale or $300 or $100 or $500 or $800
and it's cool it was a good contact you
made either they're buying from you or
they're introducing to somebody that's
gonna buy from you and Anna and then
there are people you're going to meet
and make contact with that could
completely change the face of your
business change the face of your bank
account the reaction of the banker when
you go to deposit or check because the
banker looks at you and does a double
take it's one of these things hi how are
you great I'd like to make a deposit
okay no problem hi mr. Jones it's a
different look at yet you know why
here's the look the look is a look of a
person who is super prepared and they
don't wing it anymore this is what I
mean by when I say two different types
of context you see him winging it with
every contact you made and just kind of
treat it and put it in your account and
follow up and do all that other stuff
then you can meet a person that can
completely change you to a life your
business and that one contact requires
you to do more research
you can't wing that contact you can't
copy/paste a message and send it on
Facebook or LinkedIn and make a mistake
and accidently call somebody Tom that
was mr. Jones and mr. Jones was going to
be your biggest account and mr. Jones is
so impressed by you because you actually
researched what mr. Jones does when mr.
Jones likes what mr. Jones is interested
in and what rubs mr. Jones the wrong way
and when you don't pay attention to
details like there were contacts that
are here and they have a lot more to
offer then 300 of these contacts
combined together you lose and the
reason why you're lost is because you
try to wing your way to the next level
and contacts at this level or not fools
they expect you to know what you're
doing they expect you to put that
additional energy into they expect you
to not wing yourself to the level of
doing business with them they are
insulted by your lack of research and
your lack of putting effort into it so
this is my challenge to you this week
whatever you do ask yourself am i
winging it or am I going a little bit
above and beyond am i winking it just
because I'm trying to wink it with my
talent or I'm trying to really do what a
1% or 0.1% we're doing this
game and every time you catch yourself
adjust and ask what would the point 1
percent of be doing in this same exact
situation and whatever it is adjust to
that rule number 15
stop acting helpless you'll see a lot of
times people will say but but I don't
know what to do next I just don't know I
don't know what to do how how do I learn
how to do this who's gonna teach me I
don't have a mentor I don't have money I
don't have this look today we have
access to more resources than we've ever
had in our lives how to do anything
blogs blogs YouTube there is so much
access to resources that we don't need
to act helpless we act like victims but
it's not my fault she did it's my mom
you don't saw my dad my my mom my my
sister was this my brother was as my ex
my boss my it just it's not my fault
it's the economy to market the place I
live the city the place I grew up the
school I want to everything is somebody
else's fault rule number 16 spend time
learning I want you to go on your
YouTube channel and forget about if you
don't have a YouTube channel go on the
search button above and click on history
and watch the last 20 videos you have
watched on YouTube and this is what I
want you to do categorize the videos on
which ones of them are educational and
which ones are entertainment if 50% or
more of the videos are entertainment
you're not really fully committed to
want it to become wealthy you're more
committed to become entertained and it's
not going to happen go on YouTube and
look the top 1000 videos keep going
until you find the first video that has
to do with a how-to you know how many
videos are ahead hundreds if not
thousands because most of the world
doesn't care about wanting to fully
found the secrets about business and
life and entrepreneurship they want to
be entertained this is why Hollywood
makes so much money because they know
most of the world it's full each is
committed to an entertainment that maybe
you go look at your search by the way
you can go on your history also on your
Google and look what website you visit
and what you do with your time that you
have rule number 17 get feedback
I called unhappy customers
happy customers you know my happy
customers do business with you it's an
easy call
you're amazing Patrick we love you
you're so great you always do this for
us you always do that for Ellen's you're
just such an amazing person I'm now
learning there I don't need more people
to just keep telling me how amazing how
many people to tell me these are the
three areas that we could improve it
right so I call customers that weren't
happy I call clients that weren't
happening I called agents that weren't
happy I called employees that weren't
happy and I said tell me what happened
and they gave me so much data you have
no idea how much data they give me so
much data to the point where I got
obsessed more with those conversations
than the conversations of people that
we're fully happy and next thing you
know things kept getting better and
better and better I want you to call
three to five unhappy customers and
here's what the script sounds like hey
John this is Patrick giving you call
Patrick ooh Patrick wait baby you and I
did business to get about a year and a
half we're going to decided to go a
different direction oh hey what's going
on listen I'm busy well what can I help
you with look John this is I'm not
calling to sell you I'm not calling to
get you back into the business I'm not
calling you resale you up sell you
anything like that I just have one thing
one reason why I'm calling you I am
really obsessed with getting better and
you were one of my favorite customers
that I lost and so I just wanted to call
you for you to tell me what was it that
happened for you to make a decision to
go to a different direction what was it
and there's two things you're looking
for one you're asking was it me was it
something I did or the second thing
you're asking is was it a part of the
product the part of the product is for
you don't know what adjustments to
making recommendations to make the next
time the part with you it's permanent
this is an area where you can figure out
a way to improve yourself your game and
they'll advance you to the next level
rule number 18 don't be too conservative
sometimes a smart person comes in and
they've already been taught of certain
ways or their minds already been built
up in a certain way they are way way too
conservative way way too safe and in the
world of business sometimes it gets ugly
you know sometimes it gets dirty
sometimes there are some risks you got
to take you just got a
it's not conventional risk it's not
conventional thing that I'm supposed to
be doing this no you can't lino there's
some times that you got to do some stuff
that you can't read in any book or any
video some value Taemin literally there
are certain things in business that's
like what do I do in a situation like
this I'm working on a book right now I'm
flying over to New York to talk to a
handful of major publishers because they
want me to publish this book that has to
do with specifically on how to process
issues once we learn how to process
issues but still if you're too
conservative you're gonna be toast in
the world of business there's gonna be
times in business that you have to do
certain things that no one's gonna think
about but smart people typically just go
to to abide the rules what they follow
net loss not loss not regulations rule
it's a different story they're afraid of
breaking rules sometimes conservative
people rule number 19 listen to the
right people my parents raised me a lot
of my discipline comes to my father I
love my mom I love my dad I believe
David I'm what was him for the rest of
my life but my parents are not
entrepreneurs and they're not gonna be
able to convince me how to manage my
money manage my finances they've never
owned a mutual plan that never owned the
stock they've never been millionaires
they've never been rich what can they
teach me about becoming successful in my
life by the way for some of you that are
so connected to they're like oh my gosh
that's insulting it is not insulting it
is not insulting my kids let me explain
if my kid wants to be a professional
baseball player okay
if he takes advice from me on baseball
on how to swing the ball when he goes to
the next level there's a problem there I
didn't make it to the major leagues he
needs to listen to his coach I can be a
fan and tell him hey this is what a rod
did and this is what you know ken
griffey had a beautiful swing but I'm
just a fan hit that kid better listen to
his baton coach who was in a major
league baseball the same goes with
business your parents love you your mom
and dad are great believe me everyone's
parents are mostly great they did their
best with you not everybody has perfect
parents most most people are pretty good
parents they're not gonna teach how to
become millionaires unless if they did
if they did take their counsel if they
didn't scratch their philosophy for
business go on from somebody that made a
rule number 20 get moral authority a
moral authority one more time moral
authority
my moral authority this is what I'm
talking about moral authority is when
you walk into whom everybody listens cuz
you have moral authority cuz you work
the hardest in your office cuz you
reading the books cuz you're leading the
family cuz you're doing this stuff that
you tell other people to do
that's moral authority moral authorities
why people listen to what you got to say
there's a lot of people that want to be
heard on social media hey I'm gonna go
out and be a sales trainer I don't go
out to be a motivational speaker I don't
go out there and chill around Instagram
all these other things but you need
moral authority there's only so far you
can go without have a moral authority
moral authority happens when you're
going out to do your part within
business you go self first you go show
up first you go finish the book first
you go and prove yourself first you go
change first you go lead first you go do
the work first you become better in
collaborations you become better with
people you go do it first then everybody
follows because when you do focus on
moral authority 20:18 will not only be
an incredible year by 2019
you no longer have to focus on moral
authority because it becomes part of
your DNA and word spreads which means
anybody who does business with you you
get other people with moral authority
that want to do business with you
which is higher quality people believe
me those are the types of people you
want on your team so my challenge to you
two words go get a moral authority
rule number 21 change the way you think
I often hear people say man if I had
Jeff Bezos money life would be amazing
man I wish I was wealthy like Warren
Buffett or Bill Gates or Zuck or any of
these guys Elon Musk I would love to
have their kind of money so you don't
want their money if there's anything you
would want the right answer is the
following I wish I could figure out how
they think in how they process issues if
you had Elon Musk's processor Warren
Buffett's processor you're going to make
money and by the way you're actually
going to enjoy life even more because
your processor is what you're gonna have
for the rest your life money you're
gonna run out of eventually rule number
22 believe and this is by far the
biggest challenge people have and that
is belief in order for somebody to make
this kind of
a million dollar income you're not gonna
make it if you don't believe it so you
say well Pat how do I get a chance to
believe this I never in my wildest
dreams nobody my family made this kind
of money I've not been around people
that make this kind of money how can I
make this kind of money here's the
kicker you need to master the art of
future truth now what is future truth a
lot of people have a hard time with this
let me explain so imagine if you have a
lot of doubt you don't believe in you
right you're like I don't know about
this you know this is great but me
making a million dollar income I don't
know about that yesterday I had 60
people here in my office and I said what
is it big bill about making a million
dollar income you should have seen some
people's face as well I don't really
know if I'll ever make it but it's kind
of cool to dream about having a big
house and the cars and the freedom and
few million in the bank account but I
don't know if it's for me that's because
they don't believe in it that's because
they don't understand the concept of
future truth let me explain to you the
future truth concepts some of you may
never heard of uture to it before here's
what it is if you're going to lie about
you you may as well tell a big lie to
yourself over and over and over again
now at first it's very difficult let me
describe this to you before you get
uncomfortable for instance I am going to
make a million dollar or your income now
I want you to say it say it to me real
quick stop say it I'm gonna give you a
second say it I am going to make a
million dollar your income say it again
perfect let me ask you was it
uncomfortable do you feel like you're
lying to yourself right
sometimes people show up Eric Hauck
honor was weird I feel like I'm lying to
myself if you say I am amazing I'm meant
to do something big with my life I'm the
guy that's gonna go out and be the hero
to my family that's difficult for some
people because they're lying but it's
not a it's a current lie but it's not a
future life it's a future truth it is a
current lie but it's a future truth you
see the more you tell a big lie to
yourself over and over and over and over
and over again and eventually believe it
future truth is you're gonna make a
million dollar your income this is a
belief system that is very difficult for
most people to do because most people
think every kind of lie is a bad bad
life you know I'm not telling you to go
lie to your wife about something
you're doing on the satellite your
husband about what you're doing on the
side I'm telling you tell a good lie I
don't make a difference in the world
and you don't believe it but say two
million times you're gonna end up
believing it I meant to do some special
in my life there's no way in the world
God put me on this planet to just be a
regular guy no way the blood in here is
boiling I want to do something big with
my life this guy was put on this planet
to make a difference say it over and
over and over and over and over and over
again convince everybody in the world
the entire time you're just trying to
convince one person and that is you and
that's the game of future truth and for
some of you that are maybe making $4,000
a month for the last 20 years you really
need to start lying to yourself you you
I'm talking to you
you really need to start this moment
start telling a lie to yourself on how
special of a human being you are over
and don't expect anybody else to do it
for instance when they say honey I wish
you would have told me more nicer things
mom how come you don't tell me nicer
things dad how come you don't tell me
nicer things don't wait on them start
with you rule number 23 track your data
for years I used to do the following and
then when I tell used to do the
following religiously every 19th of the
month every 19th of the month I would
run my credit okay because my credit
score back in the day so no for was for
88 for 95 for 99 if you actually watched
the life of an entrepreneur video and
you look at the credit score that I'm
looking at those are my actual
statements that was looking at from
years ago because I saved every single
one of them
I made an Excel spreadsheet and every
single week I will look at how much my
credit score improved on Equifax
Experian TransUnion I will look at how
much my checking account of my money
market account my stock portfolio my
mutual funds my investments that I had
my artifacts that was about by my my art
that I was buying my paintings that I
was buying I would always track that to
see what was going on and eventually my
credit score went from a 480 a to an 820
and the rest is history with the credit
score side but I applied that same
concept into three areas health personal
finance and business let me explain
health your weight whatever measurable
data you can get
whatever the measurable data it is that
you are trying to track maybe it's a
time you're running for the mile for two
mile 5k whatever it may be for that side
maybe it's your weight maybe it's your
body percentage maybe it's your you know
a the amount of how you did with your
diet how you feel energy wise but it's
gotta be something that you can track
data with and you measure it q1 which is
quarter one of 2018 - q4 of 2017 and I
measure - q1 of 2017 because sometimes
is season 2 season and I'm doing quarter
2 prior quarters season 2 season would
be q1 18 versus q1 17 then quarter two
quarters q1 18 - q4 17 I'm doing that
for my health and I'm doing on my
personal finance and I'm doing that for
my business on the business side
whatever data you can pull up I'm
talking specific data if you come to my
home office I have screens I can't even
tell you how many screens I have with
data all over the office because I want
to know exactly how I measure against
last year this time two years ago this
time and I want to know exactly how we
measure this quarter versus last quarter
and q1 season to season and so why is
this so important let me explain to you
why do you remember back in the days
when you took geometry and you would
have this formula and it would say
here's what's given solve this theorem
if this triangle you know this side is
three inches this is four inches how
long is this here and you were given
well it's a disagreeable and the formula
is gonna be this and the formula is
gonna be that and you go three score for
score equals you know X whatever it is
right you're solving for x and you would
make a list of all the things that are
given that you knew about and based on
the Givens you would solve for X or
whatever the answer is you trying to
figure out for business is identical the
same way okay
identically the same way there's a guy
named Billy being on baseball who
figured this thing out and came out with
the formula with a 19 year old kid on
what is the most important data to pull
up in baseball and they realize it's not
homeruns it's not doubles it's not
singles it's not triples it's not stolen
base
it's on-base percentage the more you
studied your data of your company your
business whatever you're running
eventually you're gonna figure out what
trends and what data you ought to pay
attention to most to help grow the
company continuously month to month
quarter to quarter season to season but
you got to grab a paper and pen okay and
start writing as much data that you can
track from this quarter to prior quarter
and last season's quarter and ask
yourself which one of them did you beat
by what percentage and what are you
going to be doing in q2 that's gonna
beat your q1 and q2 of 2017 rule number
24 question everything question
everything everything when your mom and
dad say something and it doesn't make
any sense like you know my heart and not
everybody's gonna make a million's honey
it's not us to make millions don't say
don't sit there and let them say it stop
them listen mom I don't believe you dad
I don't want to believe you
bro I don't want to believe you dude I'm
not with you I don't want to buy into
that concept say it to them question
them challenge them don't let them get
away with the by saying it around you
because if you sit there and you don't
question that thing nobody's you bought
into it that means you believed it you
got a question and stuff you tell
yourself stop yourself wait a minute is
that even true I don't believe you you
to yourself I don't believe what you're
saying but I don't want to believe you
I'm not buying what you just said right
now question every single thing why do I
believe this way why do I think this way
why am i wide this way
is that thinking even right why do I
even do this rule number 25 specialize
number five glides get bigger they tend
to generalize and they specialize less
let me explain when companies get bigger
they all of a sudden want to be
everything to everybody right what we're
gonna sell this and we're gonna sell
this and we're gonna sell this and we're
gonna sell this and we're gonna sell
this no problem let them do it that's
when you catch up because for you you
let go I generalize you specialize you
specialize you specialize in one area
let them generalize and then when
they're generalizing they're grown like
this where you grown like this and then
you catch up when you're specializing
then all of a sudden boom you decide at
that moment what things to pivot but you
got to catch up in order to catch up to
your guy or gal that you're competing
against
you got to specialize don't get caught
up trying to be everything to everybody
and sell every single product rule
number 26 worry about the right opinions
we're number six you worry too little
about what the right people think about
you what are the right people the right
people are the people that are helping
you get to the next level the right
people are the customers that are buying
from you the right people are the people
that are trying to give you an education
about business entrepreneurship growing
you worry too little about these guys
you worry way too much about the people
that have no desire to help you get to
the next level zero rule number 27
exercise when you come to work and you
haven't exercised you're lethargic
sometimes it takes an hour or two before
you even get into the flow of doing
things right when you exercise prior to
coming to work your mind is sharper
right off to better you just kind of
want to get into it you're in a flow of
things you're going you're moving you're
coming up with better ideas better ways
of you know having this thing advanced
to the next level what if we do this
what if we do that what if we do this
everything that's better because your
mind is sharper if you don't have energy
you can't solve problems why because so
think about it this way if you're in a
room in a boardroom everybody's going
back and forth trying to solve problems
and you see everybody do this one signal
let me tell what the signal is this is
the signal you're ready this is the
signal of somebody saying we should just
figure something out and leave the
boardroom this is how it looks like you
know what the signal is what is a signal
I want to go home right this signals I
want to finish this meeting here we
should already wrap up you could have
been seven minutes away from solving
this problem in a way so effective that
would have helped you take your business
to the next level but you were so tired
because you're lethargic from not
exercising not having proper diet now
you just made the good decision instead
of the best decision so you don't
advance to the next level I'm by the way
this happens in sports this happens in
business
this happens in everything you watch
because you can tell when decisions are
made and this is what happens the person
goes like this ah let's just do it
that's not the best decisions that's
just a decision it's not the best
decision the best decision is
if we do this add us if we do this it
does this if we do this it does this
here let's write the center that that
you know what I think this is the best
situation we're moving with this what do
you guys think great let's move forward
rule number 28 work hard point number
eight you will be hospitalized for
burnout or hard work multiple times
Mario knows it's watching this from you
know behind the camera is this has
happened to me multiple times one time
we're in Jacksonville and I'm giving
this talk in Jacksonville and while I'm
speaking my legs are wobbly it looks
like I'm about to pass out the room is
full it is hot it's summertime we finish
I walk out I'm walking in the parking
lot with Paul all of a sudden I collapse
I tell Paul take me to the emergency
room we get in the RV I go to the
emergency room they set me up with IVs I
say doc what's going on with me since
you're just exhausted they gave me two
IVs I was fired up we got in the RV
drove down to Miami stayed up to three
four five o'clock in the morning did it
again the next day why cuz that's the
stuff you're gonna do a few times when
you push the envelope it's just gonna be
happening now by the way some parents
will watch us and say I can't believe
you my kids are watching you tell it my
kid admires you how dare you see this
kind of stuff to my kids ma'am
sir let me simplify something for you
the chances of your kid even doing this
is less than one percent because the
person who's gonna do this is already
thinking about this stuff they just want
some direction I want to know when they
face off a glide so don't worry about
your kid there's one percent chance that
your kids even gonna want to step up to
something like this rule number 29 don't
make excuses
point number nine you're an expert at
making excuses literally everything that
happens in your life you got a great
excuse for everything I couldn't show up
it was raining I was sick I had a flu my
dog was sick my mom wasn't in a good
mood such-and-such happen you know this
isn't what happened my leg I was
cramping I had a hard workout you don't
understand my favorite team is playing
excuse girl or for everything if you
have that money is just not attracted to
excuses just kind of how this thing
works
rule number 30 developed discipline my
guaranteed formula for success that is
100% proven for my life and other people
have taught out work out improve outlast
and out strategies again out work out
improve outlets out strategize what
you're looking on the screen here on the
screen look at those four again what
you're looking on on the screen here
which of those four things that you're
looking at the out work out improve
outlets out strategize which of those
four things do you think comes last
meaning you'll learn the latter the
latest it's out strategize why because
that requires a lot of experience it's
like you got to go through like a
general in the war right you got to go
through so many different words to learn
different strategies and what works and
what tactics works and what doesn't work
that's something you gotta be working on
right however the other three out work
if a guy works 80 hours a week and you
work 40 hours a week you can't compete
with that guy if some if you yourself
are reading two three four books a month
and you develop in your mind and your
competitor is not and you only reads one
or two and you study in industry
articles and all the subs and they're
not you know you're studying how to
recruit CEO CFO CEO CMOS what is the
best way to stretch this million dollar
investment that I got to make this
happen who should I talk to to be part
of a group for mentors and CEOs group
and all these who should I network with
what community should I be a part of
who's the best engineers IT firm to hire
what are these competitors doing what
are some of the guys that are not even
on my mark if you start studying those
industry somebody else isn't it's tough
to compete with you and then outlast
some people work 80 hours a week for a
year and that's great but they can't
work 80 hours a week for three years
some work 80 hours a week for three
years but you work 80 hours a week for
five years you outlasted the guy that
the three years are one year they can't
compete with you because the compounding
effort favors you so these four things
that you look at on the screen require
one thing and that's discipline and the
discipline part you don't hear a lot
about that's the things people doing
nobody else sees that's when you win
rule number 31 leave negative people
behind whatever you want to do in your
life you got to kind of leave your
comfort zone the friends the family the
cousins that you hang out with all the
time that know you for who you are
you're saying this is who I may be today
but man I want this life and for you to
do this you got to leave them behind do
you know how many friends I had that
when I was deciding to go and spread my
wings this was the one line you ready
here's a line hey Pat so have you made
your millions yet path things is gonna
be a millionaire guys where's the
millions huh I used to see you drive a
Ford Expedition now you come with a Ford
Focus you are definitely becoming a
million it looks
going backwards more than anything I
remember all these stories every one of
them I went from a big Ford Expedition
I'd go to all the parties everybody
would go in my car and we go together I
lost everything 49k in debt and boom I
pull up in a Ford Focus that I can
barely fit in everyone would say this is
the guy that's gonna be a millionaire
you're the guy that's gonna be somebody
we should fall on do business with give
me a flippin break and I was hated by my
friends for five years cuz I have to
leave them behind you want to come with
me let's go you don't want to come in no
problem I got to go do what I got to do
you're never gonna pay my bills and I'm
not paying your bills I got to go do my
part not to go out there and do it it is
not an easy thing to do but if you're
watching this you're going through it if
you truly are serious with the effort
backed up to it go out and get exactly
what you want rule number 32 take
responsibility in life I've lost many
many times let me tell you many times
I've had girlfriends break up with me
I've had companies somebody didn't want
to do business with me I've had an
employee tell me they don't want to be
with me how that sales people that have
quit on me I've had so many people that
have had losses with I've competed
against people that are inferior than me
and I lost to them because that better
work ethic than me and I thought because
I had some talent that the time I was
gonna beat him no way in the world that
guy worked harder than me and I've also
competing against guys that were
superior than me and I worked my butt
off and I still lost I still lost with a
guy that was ahead of me what happened
there I worked my ass off and I still
lost yes that also happens it's called
the loss it hurts it's embarrassing you
come home your wife or your girlfriend
mom wants to make you feel good but you
know your loss and it doesn't feel good
your peers are looking at your
competitors are looking at you the smirk
that competitor is gonna have when they
give you a high-five where they shake
their hand to kind of say good luck to
you next time you know that look still
says that I beat you that hurts a girl
breaks up with you that hurts
but here's the kicker here's the kicker
in that moment you will have a
temptation
it's the biggest temptation in life it's
the most dangerous tenth temptation a
lot it's the most powerful temptation
like let me tell you what it is in that
moment you will have the choice of
either blaming something on the outside
or taking for responsibility that
temptation is so subtle no one knows it
no one knows it I have led thousands of
sales people that I've worked with and
I've seen some of them keep growing
growing growing growing
one guy went from 30 grandeur to 50
grand new 200 grandeur to 200 300 400
500 600 700 million-dollar your income
while they had a lot of drama fast in
three years what happened to them they
never blamed they always took
responsibility
they never blamed and I've had people
that are ten times more talented every
six months to have some kind of a subtle
stop you know why because they blame the
different circumstance well because of
this because it's this person's fault
that person's well this person's fault
look in life it's gonna be very easy for
you to blame everybody very easy for you
gonna for you to blame everybody but one
day you'll sit down and people will say
how come you didn't make it bigger in
life you were very talented what
happened there you can make up any BS
and sell them because typically people
who are good at blaming other people are
great salespeople you can blame
everybody else but there's one person
that's gonna know that you didn't take
responsibility and that's you that's a
tough one to live with rule number three
three be a long-term thinker well number
three is long-term thinking the best
example of long-term thinking is one of
the richest men in the world and that's
Warren Buffett I want you to look at
this chart that I'm gonna put up and the
part I want to look at is how his wealth
grew from eighteen years old
to his 81 billion dollars today that
doesn't include the billions of dollars
that is given away to charity so let's
take a look at this guy named Warren
Buffett one of the richest wisest
smartest investors in the world how did
he amass as well so at the age of 19 he
had $10,000 to his name the first
million dollars he made he was 32 years
old give or take fast-forward to the age
of 40 years old you'll notice he had a
thirty four million dollar net worth
right now watch what happens here from
34 million dollars the next year or two
it goes from 34 million dollars to 19
million dollars I think as much as we
spend time talking about how rich this
man is we forget to talk about this
moment in his career let me explain to
you why do you know how many people in
the world when they drop on 34 million
to 19 million dollars that's 50% of the
waters gone what do you think most
people do they cash out they take their
money out they listen to news the news
the saying world you know it's the
world's coming to an end war is coming
through you know this is what's gonna
happen that's what's gonna happen price
of oil oh my gosh panic panic panic
panic panic everyone reacts this guy
says I trust my discipline because I'm a
long-term thinker and watch what happens
here he goes from 19 million dollars to
67 million dollars two billion dollars
at fifty six to eighty 1 billion dollars
today let me compare his net worth to
some of the countries in the world watch
this year
Guatemala he's got more than Guatemala
Costa Rica Luxembourg Slovenia Serbia
Tunisia Ghana arooga Kenya Ethiopia
Lebanon Bulgaria boos Beckett's town
Croatia Lithuania Warren Buffett is
beating those countries one human being
is beating countries
rule number 34 shoes success one of the
scariest moments of my life was the day
I realized I'm Tony it's very scary that
day I realize I can have exactly the
life that I want to have this doesn't
mean you can go become whoever you want
to be not at all I didn't think I can go
be LeBron James I don't jump 44 inches
and I'm not six eight to 80
I can't sail you can go become anybody
one you can go be Michael Phelps no you
can't these are very obvious things to
know not everybody can be Michael Phelps
right I can't go today decide to become
Michael Phelps I can't go today decide
to become the next Ted Williams
I can't certain things you cannot do and
that's okay
not everybody can go out there and do a
lot of things other people are doing
however however logically and
emotionally let me explain it to you
last night we're having dinner okay and
if you had crustaceans the armed family
this place in Beverly Hills is just an
incredible restaurant and I'm speaking
to my sister and I said let me ask you a
question
she said yeah everybody's like whatever
yes I said out of what we ate tonight
what did we know that we shouldn't have
eaten if we didn't want to put on more
weight or carry on more additional carbs
starch whatever may be right and
everybody said well noodles said what
else well the the the the dessert we
just said okay what else and so we went
through it right though you know the the
crabs that we had that the lobster W had
a lot of oil in it okay great
why do we eat it
because we chose to eat it why do we eat
it cuz it's good okay but we ate it yeah
but we know it's not good right yes but
we ate it yes so that's a scary thing
let me explain to you why we know if we
ate it we have to 2x2 cardio the next
day and if we don't eat it we don't have
to to X the cardio the next day because
if we - it's the car to you the next day
we're getting closer to getting shredded
right or looking better or cutting some
bringing out more the muscle being more
defined be more vascular but we ate we
chose to eat it okay the same goes that
no one needs to teach you and I that if
you drink a lot the night before an
important sale in the morning so you go
out there Wednesday night after
everything is done you go ham get
hammered you party till 1 o'clock in the
morning and you got an 8 o'clock
appointment a morning to close if I
don't drink and I prepare 10 times more
than you do and you drink you get
hammered you party you stay up and you
come the next day lethargic I'm gonna
close the deal over you are over you you
know that I know that so what happens
there here's the scary part every one of
the decisions you make you know stain on
newsfeed Facebook isn't good for you
because you can read a book instead of
that you know it you know yourself going
party in three four times a week is not
good you know nobody needs to tell you
that you know it you know exercising is
good for you you know it no one needs to
make five more million videos to tell
you that you need to go out there and
you know what to do you know it so
logically you know what to do you know
what not to eat you know exercise is
good for you you know communication
works you know reading books works you
know all this stuff why you choose not
to do it is the other part so let me
give you the emotional side of it the
emotional side of it is we're such great
sales people because we convinced
ourselves we have a lot of time left we
convinced ourselves that I can do it
tomorrow man I'm only 22 I can do it
tomorrow only 39 I mean she's got half
my life to live young I mean my twenties
I should party I'm only 90 I should go
out there and just hang out who cares
about being the indiscipline I can't
learn discipline of my 40s
right I don't need to take your my body
I'm 25 I'm hot I'm a girl I'm drop-dead
gorgeous I don't need to work out I'm
hot at 35 when it goes it goes so you
emotionally sell yourself on not having
to do the work so now you watching this
there's two different kinds of people
one person's like I was hoping to get
motivated oh my gosh I wanna I want you
to motivate no no the second person is
watching this says this I control the
kind of a life I can build and live why
am I not making the right choices to be
able to build a life for myself I don't
know
only you can answer that not me not
anybody else only you I had to choose
others had to choose what are you going
to choose now here's another part of the
scary part you're gonna be seven years
old overnight I promise you go by so
quick who are we gonna be 55 years old
overnight
I look around you look at your parents
did you think your parents were gonna be
that age did you didn't you think your
parents were gonna be around for a long
time some of you guys don't have your
mom and dad here with you I'm here in LA
right now for one reason my dad's
brother passed away I'm at a funeral
that's 66 years old he passed away no
one expected this man to pass away in
Iran he passed away that's why I'm in LA
life goes by quickly
the sooner you and I choose to make the
decisions that we know are right for you
and I that you have control over the
sooner we start getting the kind of
results that get us to the dream life
that we want to live the only challenge
is you have to make the right choices
and no one else can do that for you rule
number 35 face the monster under your
bed face the monster on your bed let me
tell what I mean by facing the monster
under your bed as kids some kids go to
sleep and they feel like there's a
monster under their bed like think about
that was a kid I was afraid to put on my
arm out you know why because I thought
there was a monster under the bed I
don't know if you had this I was afraid
of how my legs out the blanket had to
cover me I'm telling you as a kid and
this somebody might say you're out of
your mind some of you may say that's
that was me I was afraid what if my leg
is at a monster pulls my lickers you
would see this you know my sister would
intentionally put nightmares on
Nightmare on Elm Street you know my
Freddy Krueger could be coming out on
both go to sleep dreaming about Freddy's
under your bed Freddy what was that one
song with Freddy Freddy hung it then and
how did it go on - he's looking for you
I'm sure they're putting the song up for
you to hear that song screwed with my
head in Iran I was more scared of Freddy
Krueger than Saddam Hussein Iran and
Saddam used to bomb us all the time it
doesn't matter you gotta face it as
simple as go under your bed and realize
there's nobody there look in the in the
shown narcos the character Steve Murphy
whom I just said with a couple weeks ago
any was interview is gonna come out of
here pretty soon he says the following
thing and I think it's like season 2
episode number 11 or something like that
when when they kill Pablo he says all
that time hunting him and just like that
I'm looking down at Pablo effing Escobar
for years I've been building up this son
of a [ __ ] in my head what a monster hit
be but here's the thing when you lay
eyes on him the devil's a real letdown
just a man
beer grown doesn't shave fat and
shoeless you know what his point is
Pablo was this big he was a devil he was
evil can be taken down everyone was
afraid of him and then he's dead when
you face your fears and you look at him
you're so disappointed because it's not
a big deal it's very simple once you
face it for so many people they never
have that moment that Steve Murphy had
an in the show narcos or in real life
against Pablo Escobar they don't have it
so some people are 85 and that fear is a
reality because they never faced it
rule number 36 minimize regrets regret
minimization I've spoken about in a
couple other videos minimize the number
of regrets when you look back you don't
wanna be able to say I messed up here
with drugs I did this year I did the
divorce I did that oh my gosh I got it
so many dumb mistakes I made that you
could have prevented yourself on making
uh for some of you that are saying I
feel bad because I just went through
divorce three years later you make me
feel bad our current president is on a
third marriage you're okay
just minimize the amount of regrets that
you're gonna have because it doesn't
stunt the momentum that you have your
best friend and accumulating wealth as
momentum don't get in the way of
momentum water it so gets bigger and
bigger
and bigger rule number 37 address
conflicts I want today not a big fan of
dead weight for a longest time I somehow
someway always had some dead weight but
the dead weight is when you and your
mind know you have a conflict with an
individual but you don't want to address
it the longer you delay that the issue
gets bigger and bigger both for you and
the other person now this is assuming
this is a person you want to have a
relationship with and now that could be
an ego saying it which you don't you do
you're just trying to be cocky about it
I'm not talking about that I'm talking
sincerely I honestly don't want to have
a relationship with this person I'm okay
about it great that's not the person I'm
talking about I'm talking about the
person you do want to have a
relationship with that is critical for
the success of your business and it is
critical for the success of your
happiness and your life this could be
family you got to get on the phone with
them ASAP I made four calls today I made
four yesterday I had a sit down each of
them brings around an hour and a half to
three hours to an hour and a half each
call there was a conflict there they
were all different types of conflicts
there isn't a single one that was
similar to the other one not a single
one of them but they all were conflicts
we got on the phone tension in the first
17 seconds 30 seconds call continues
then it's solid then it's open you're
open I want to talk about it are you
open to you let's talk about it listen
this matters to me if it matters to you
let's address it great there was things
that I'll sit in as citizen I'm not
comfortable with this decision that we
made okay great yeah I'm not comfortable
with the decision we made here this is
my thoughts you want me to tell you my
thoughts or if you just wanted we kind
of keep it to myself no share with me
your thoughts here's why I think about
this well here's what I think about this
great there is a resolution if you're
willing right in my career eventually I
got to a point I said listen I don't
have any time for this I'm getting on
the phone making these calls if they
matter 95% of the calls I made and I got
on the phone with the individual and we
addressed the dead weight 95% of the
time we solved it a hundred percent of
the time when I didn't call it it was
always wrong and a guy worse and worse
and worse
rule number 38 have integrity I know a
lot of times people say well that person
is a little bit you know it's
interesting how he is I don't know he
kind of will go to the gray area or
he'll go to this area who go to that
area fine other people want to say that
no problem
people who stay with a founder for long
enough over time they know that person
may be crazy but there are certain
things they're not gonna cross if you
cross the line there how would you keep
the best talent how would you keep the
best smart people around you're just not
gonna do it if you struggle with
integrity you're gonna lose a lot of
people that is a quality so necessary I
think Warren Buffett said there's three
things he likes right energy integrity
and competency I think those were the
three things he says without integrity
forget the other two right I want to say
those are the three things that yet the
point is to build a big business you
need people around you to trust you just
as much as you trust them that requires
integrity rule number 39 network
networking look I can take my business
back to 1999 when I went to a man's
house it was a millionaire and he had a
big party and I made a lot of
relationships after the relationship two
years later he introduced me to a guy
that introduced me to a guy in 2003 that
contact is what led me to making thirty
million dollars just off of one sale you
know I went to an insurance conference a
few years ago met a guy we didn't hit it
off we had a terrible call together one
time I'm talking a 5-minute call that
was horrible horrible call I said we'll
never do business with this guy he came
back saying I still want your business
what can we do to make this work we made
it work fast forward he's the one that
ended up putting me in contact with De
La Hoya and couple other guys that
raised ten million dollars for business
these were contacts we networked we went
through it look at Zuckerberg he goes to
Harvard meets a kid named Edward meets
the Winklevoss brothers that leads to
Facebook you look at Warren Buffett who
networks and meets a guy named Charlie
Munger who he thinks is smarter than he
is and that bring those two together
build the empire that they built
everything's about networking in your
context especially if you want to
increase your wealth let me put it to
you this way it is very difficult for
billionaires to befriend somebody that's
for $20,000 very difficult you know why
because the experiences are different
and level of thinking is different if
you hang with a billionaire your $20,000
somehow someway is gonna get higher
somehow someway this thing it's hard
because you're borrowing their thinking
you're borrowing who they know you're
borrowing their associations rule number
40 tell great stories so one day I'm
sitting in the sales appointment and
this guy walks and he looks very sharp
and I'm looking at the sky I said man he
looks sharper why does he smell so bad
like he smells terrible did he just go
to the bathroom like man wipe yourself
clean yourself what is wrong with you
he smelled terrible and he's sitting in
front of me and typically an appointment
sales appointment would take me an hour
hour and a half and said listen I can't
sit next to somebody that smells this
bad so I cut this appointment fast I was
very frustrated said how does somebody
have the audacity to not even take care
of themselves when they come in I mean
his shoes did you step on poop what is
wrong with you
so I cut the appointment very quickly
and I said buddy I got another call I
gotta make we're good to go so he leaves
I go I'm out listen to this guy man I
haven't seen a guy that smelled this bad
I've never done a poem with a guy that
smells bad so I go to the bathroom and
when I go to the bathroom and I look at
myself in the mirror I had my kids
earlier and when I had my kids earlier
on my tie is poop all the way on my tie
okay and the person who smelled like she
was this guy here not the guy I'm
selling it to it was embarrassing
because the entire time the man was so
kind so nice to me and you can see the
stains on my tie here he never brought
it up if you're watching this my
apologies to you I promise you moving
forward I will never have poop on my tie
ever again but if you've ever done a
sales appointment and you're worried
about how I wanted these things in your
teeth you know how and you look at
something identica take that thing out
nothing is gonna be worse than having
poop on your time rule number 41
persevere I talk to a lot of people who
are about to have a breakthrough right
they're about to have a breakthrough
but they have convinced themselves in
here of one thing and let me tell you
what it is they've convinced themselves
that what they're going through no one's
ever gone through before that their wall
is bigger than everybody else's wall
that their difficulty no one knows how
hard it is but you don't know what I'm
going through but you don't know my
different you don't know my family you
don't know my heartache you don't know
my enemy you don't know who I'm facing
you don't know this opponent he's so
manipulative you don't know how the
industry is you don't know how to market
this you don't know the company I'm a
part you don't everything that's said
you don't know my wife you don't know my
boyfriend you don't know my husband you
don't know my parents you don't know who
I am
my difficulties are bigger than your
difficulties
and that's why I can't overcome these
difficulties to make space up to you you
know it's dangerous and you actually
believe that because if you actually
believe it you are right there's nobody
else that can do any convincing for you
but it's in that moment look at
Hollywood do you think everybody in
Hollywood is a good actor honestly I can
name you 20 people that are terrible
actors who have had a career of 20-plus
years you can as well but they
persevered they believe they belong in
that space
even though how many auditions you think
that got passed up on you think in
basketball everybody's got a god-given
talent do you think Steph Curry can jump
like LeBron James or Vince Carter I
would say Vince Carter's got god-given
abilities I don't know just have Kris
got the same kind of god-given abilities
as LeBron or Vince Carter or any of
these guys in baseball you think
everybody's got this perfect 20/20
vision like Ted Williams had it's a lot
of guys that hit a wall that had to
overcome a lot of guys that had to play
triple-a for a couple years before
somebody picked them up a lot of them so
is in business but no matter what you're
doing anticipate the wall you're going
to hit it and in those moments whatever
you tell yourself if you convince
yourself that the difficult your face
and it's harder than everybody else's
and you buy it you will stay where
you're at but if you convince yourself
that whatever you wall you've hit other
people I've overcoming and so can you
you go through that wall wall as well
rule number 42 don't be too logical
Paulo Coelho the author of The Alchemist
once said that when we turn when you and
I turn 23 24 years old our brain
something happens to it where we become
more logical we're no longer oh my gosh
this is possible I can take over the
world
I don't know if I can really take over
see it's kind of impossible if you
really think about it there's no way in
the world we can build something like
this
so we go into this whole different state
of thinking right now the possibility
thinking is not out there
let me explain to a little bit more
about this go back 2011 seven years ago
I'm in my room in my office in Woodland
Hills Y by Warner Wonder Center Marriott
I have made a friend I had known him for
four or five years we don't business
together
very smart guy loved him loved his wife
good-looking family went to
Wharton Business School sharp as hell
brilliant guy he comes to me after
meeting at Cheesecake Factory because he
says I'd like to invest I want you to be
the CEO I want to be your CEO or
president we go with this company to get
us a great let's meet so we finally meet
in the office it's 12:30 we're about to
finalize the information to go into
contract and the number we agreed at
this time there's nothing taking place
good at this time with the company we're
trying to build that it's a lot of work
but we've been around for a year and a
half there's some track record so we
come up with this number around a half a
million dollars for 10% of company you
know what he ends up telling me that not
here's what he says you know what
Patrick I said what's that I feel like
you're very good negotiator and you're
very good in sales I said ok that's
that's a good thing I'm that that just
means that you're very smart to team up
with somebody like that that's a very
good salesperson negotiated because
you've told me before that's not your
strength your strength is more
operational technology yes I said so
what do you want to team up with a guy
that is opposite strengths - who's
nodding that in sales and I go I'm
trying to and somewhat you're train with
this he says why I just don't know if
I'm gonna get the best deal here I said
let me get this straight you're getting
10% for only half a million dollars and
I'm doing this because I want you part
of our team I just think you're selling
me there's some stuff I don't know about
I said ok no problem
we went our separate ways do you realize
the food a came with that investment his
investments gonna be somewhere between
15 to 20 million dollars today and he
would have excelled what happened
Wharton Business School way too logical
everything was about well what if this
happens what if that happens was just
almost watch him thinking he went all
logical he didn't see the emotional side
he didn't see the social capital
division what we are going on and he was
afraid because he's second-guess
themselves you know you know what it's
like let me explain a little bit deeper
for years so it makes sense to you when
you're 16 you're a girl you're in high
school 10th grade 11th grade someone
flirts with you it's cute you like you
like oh my gosh I think he likes me it's
nice if you share with your friends when
you're 45 you're single maybe divorce
and you meet another man he's divorced
and you meet him somewhere he comes and
talks to you the approach sometimes is
different you know what happens here's
what happens wait a minute I know what
you're trying to do you're floating with
me right yes I know what you want you
only care about one thing you're just
trying to get in my pants I'm sorry what
do you mean all you want from me is once
all men all they want is one thing
skeptic logical when you're skeptic
logical guy says eventually I'm hoping I
get into your pants because that's what
people if I like you like me we should
probably go in the bedroom and have some
fun together right yeah you know you
you're not yes what's wrong if I'm
flirting with you I'm trying to woo you
and chase you sometimes your dreams are
floating with you but you're not letting
your dreams for it because all you're
doing is saying I know what you're
trying to do with me you're just trying
to get into my pants of course your
dreams are trying to get into your pants
your dreams is here they want to get
into here you're not letting your garden
down so you don't let anybody in you
know what happens when you do that you
live a life with no dreams becoming a
reality do you really want their life if
you don't want that life you have to
open this up a little bit and you have
to set aside some of the logical
thinking allow for opportunities come up
that get you closer and closer and
closer to dreams
rule number 43 be tough I think
sometimes we want an easy life so I
think sometimes we want everybody to
love us and buy from us and so easy it's
so great it's all the sudden and with
all my monitoring treatments she didn't
tell me I was special my dad didn't do
this to me my ex cheated on me my ex did
this and this person did this and my
friend did this and my boss oh my gosh
this is why I'm losing both those are
all the reasons why you have a shot at
doing something big with your life those
are all the reasons those are all the
reasons why you can use as an ammunition
to say boom worl bomb coming I'm gonna
do something big with my life and no one
expects it so rather than looking at
some of these tough times that you may
be going through today and there you
will be going through in the future
because depending on whatever age you
are you go from going to birthdays to go
into weddings to go on to birthday kids
being born to go into kids birthday
parties then you go to funerals no
matter what we're all going to funerals
eventually if you haven't already
started going to funerals that's called
life and the sooner you anticipate tough
times and the sooner you overcome every
single one of these tough times that you
think you're the only one that's going
through it when are you gonna look up
and people gonna look at you as an
example of somebody who is tough enough
to go through the difficult times and
now they're a leader winning big and
they one day want to be just like you
rule number 44 trust your vision
when a person that's new in sales and
new as an entrepreneur you know starts
doing their business they get
disappointed very quickly because they
don't realize you can do everything
right with a client with an agent with
an employee with a salesperson you can
do everything right and they can still
change your minds why because people
often change your minds people are
emotional beings or pack what should I
put my focus into should I not trust
people I don't know if I'm saying that
this is what I'm saying to you I know I
can control my effort I can't control
everybody's effort I can't control my
attitude I can't control everybody's
attitude I can control me keeping my
ward I can't control everybody keeping
their word I can control me not changing
my mind all the time
I can't control people changing their
minds all the time I can control how I'm
gonna behave on a daily basis I can do
the other side
by the way systems are not emotional you
can control systems people are emotional
you can't control people trust systems
drive systems trust your mission trust
your vision trust your crew say trust
what your vision is long-term on what
you're gonna be able to do at the
beginning stages have you being a
salesperson or an entrepreneur you can't
do that with people because they're
gonna often change your minds now does
this mean it's always gonna be like that
not at all why the longer your own
business you eventually find a group of
people that buy into you you eventually
find a group of people that understand
how consistent you are you eventually
find a group of people that want to be
in business with you forever you
eventually find a group of people that
like your style you eventually find a
group of people that like your vision
your crusade your cause your mission and
your vision is so big that other
people's vision also fits into it but it
won't happen right off the bat and so
while you're watching this video and
you're asking yourself oh my gosh you
know III if I land this one client it's
gonna make me $300,000 it's gonna change
my life I can't wait to land this client
if I land at one sales guy he's the best
in the market I gotta get this guy what
happens if they change their minds do
you also change your mind what happened
if they say no do you also get down on
yourself and say oh my gosh I don't have
to business for me no
don't let other people's emotions and
decisions and constant changing their
minds dictate your mind you focus on
your vision your mission and long-term
things that you want to do with your
life and eventually you'll find enough
people that want to run with you
rule number 45 learn continuously if I
was to ask you this one question here
watch this how many guys have a
four-year degree raisin if you got a
four-year degree okay now watch this
keep your hands up please keep your hand
up I'm really curious how many of you
that have a four-year degree in the last
30 days you've finished a business book
that's the problem
why so what's the point of a degree some
ants are still up was it just to get a
degree in that education is gonna be
done you know what that's kind of like
me saying that's like me saying to
following when I was 14 to 18 years old
I exercise every day and that's it come
on how we stay in shape you know I don't
know why my six-pack is not coming I
used to have it when I was 22 I'm 42 no
no we need to workout today
right we need to educate ourselves today
not what we did 20 years ago so I don't
have any problem with our people that
get degrees I have a problem with us not
endorsing self education I have a
problem with the fact that we need four
years to go to college nowadays we're
snapchat comes out the next thing comes
out the next thing comes out we have to
move so quick that a four-year degree is
too slow to school and our educational
system needs to be adjusted very very
quickly
rule number 46 get rid of negative
people let's just say you have the best
mentor in the world that you get to
choose anybody pick them Pat I'd love to
have you as a mentor maybe Tony maybe
Elon pick whoever you think is the best
mentor for you and imagine if you have
this person in your life and
simultaneously you have five negative
people in your life okay so one
incredible mentor and five absolutely
negative people in your life who do you
think wins I mean serious who do you
think wins do you think even with those
five negative people in your life and
this one in
terrible mentor do you think you're
still gonna end up winning who's more
powerful you see there's this whole
notion that people think if I had this
incredible mentor Pat I'm gonna kill it
in life even with the five negative
people in my life it's not how it works
see it doesn't work that way those five
and negative people have way more
influence on your life than that one
incredible mentor and here's why think
about these people that are super
successful how many people think have
worked with them directly think about it
how many people think Elon is touched
how many people think Steve touched
Gates is touched
Tony's touched how many people think
they've touched how come not all of them
became successful they're incredible
mentors aren't they why is that she
because even the most ridiculous mentor
in the world can't stop those five
negative people that steal all the
dreams from your mind and from your
heart they don't have that kind of
influence so that negative cousin of
yours that calls you [ __ ] and all the
time you got to stop picking up his
calls that friend of yours that's always
spreading gossip to you about
everybody's personal life you got to
stop picking up her calls that best
friend of yours from high school who
thinks rich people are greedy and they
suck she is sucking all your dreams out
of you and you don't even know it rule
number 47 fight there is the one
audience that says I don't believe in
competition I believe in domination I
don't want to compete because it's for
sissies i dominate people then there's a
group that says I don't I don't think
competitions good or dominations good
I believe in collaboration I like to
collaborate let's figure out a way to do
stuff together which is fine but then
there's this group hidden group secretly
some of the most fierce crazy
competitors in the world we know what
happened to them few years ago maybe
they were in high school
crow broke up with them they lost the
football game in front of friends family
girlfriend husband wife they were
humiliated and they said oh my gosh this
is so hurtful people saw me lose I am so
embarrassed
I will never compete ever again I've had
some humiliating losses in the past
before and it's made me become timid but
this is what I respect
you got sometimes put these up I say
listen I don't know if I'm gonna be sure
now but I'm gonna fight you here's what
I'm going to be doing I'm getting in the
flippin arena let's see what happens in
the arena if I'm not good I'm gonna get
better and come back but if I'm good I
want to fight the next guy that's how
you get better by the way that's part of
life is well that's what makes it juicy
to want to keep getting better
rule number 48 change your mindset
people are going to try to change you in
two different ways okay one there's
gonna be people that want to help you
change your mindset you know and change
your mindset and the way you view things
that's a different story but then
there's gonna be people that are gonna
try to change you
the way you are with your personality
and those people that try to change you
with your personality on the way you're
wired you have to be very careful with
that because if you allow somebody to
convince you to change your personality
not your mindset you in a way could take
that as maybe you're not good enough
NSPS
it's complete BS have to battle with the
people that end up winning at the
highest level you know what they have
they end up believing that they can win
at the highest level that the way
they're wired is worthy enough to win at
the highest level that's the mindset
there are different personalities than
you I've seen people that are quiet
timid and people think they're weak and
they become presidents you've seen
people that are loud and very loud and
obnoxious and they become president so
it doesn't mean just one type of
personality once every type of
personality when sistah mindset so don't
let anybody convince you that your
personality and the way your wiring is
not here here that has to change
that's not worthy enough what needs to
change is your mindset is the way you
view the world is the way you view
things money life marriage business
freedom relationships those processing
that you have here it's okay to change
those things but not your personality
your personality is perfect just the way
it is all the other things you can work
on rule number 49
sleep sweat grime
mind repeat one of the biggest
contradictions of massive success is
when people go to their moms their dads
their brothers sister
boyfriend/girlfriend they say listen one
day the world's gonna Know Who I am
one day I will have a Ferrari the land
with the Rose the Bentley the big house
the cars the backyard with the big
swimming pool and an elevator I'm up
with the biggest parties people are
gonna stop me at the mall mom people
gonna stop me at the airport and take
pictures I mean take selfies with me and
tell me oh my gosh you changed my life
I'm gonna be a millionaire one day yet
instead of staying at the office on
Friday night you call your friends you
go party instead of waking up Saturday
morning to go to the gym you sleep in
till 10 o'clock instead of reading the
book on Sundays you kick back and watch
movies all day long see the reality is
very simple those who win big they do
four things right
they sleep sweat wine repeat
and they do it over and over and over
again under their dreams become a
reality
if you're thinking and you st. Pat
there's no way in the world it can be
that easy listen let me break it down
for you this whole concept of sleep
sweat grind repeat comes down to a few
things you gotta do when you out work
you out improve you out strategize you
outlast your peers your competitors five
10 years from now not only will you be a
rockstar in your industry but that
Ferrari that Lambo that Bentley that
rose was that big house with the
elevator the big parties that fame the
accolades the respect all of those
things will become a reality if you
sleep sweat grind repeat
and rule number 50 the last told me for
a very special bonus clip is have fun
running the sales office back in 2005 in
Granada Hills okay and I always came in
on Sundays because Sunday's things were
quiet I could really strategize and
write stuff down to know what I'm gonna
be doing the next week one Sunday I go
in and I'm like wait a minute nobody
parks the car here on Sundays this is
not a place you park the car on Sundays
in Granada Hills right after four or
five freeway two cars are parked outside
so what's going on here so I come
upstairs and by the way there was a way
for you to always sneak into the office
on Sunday because if you had one of
those you know how you put the ID stuff
in the door you know which one I'm
talking on that door opens so there was
a way to sneak in but I came in from the
elevator I put my keys in and I'm
hearing stuff what is this is it the
cleaning crew okay this is not a sound I
recognize for cleaning it shouldn't
sound like this in a moment I opened
Dora it's like you know when it's like
too late when you see something you know
it was too late already and I saw it and
this couple boyfriend and girlfriend
they're going at it as if they're
shooting a porn movie that day and I'm
watching these guys like the sound
cha-cha loud I'm like and you look at me
like you know the whole look you mean if
you cover your so I'm like guys I'm
uncomfortable what are you guys doing
here
second everybody's doing one of these
things right oh my gosh Patrick we're so
sorry I said why here why not in your
apartment why not in your house but Pat
I live with my parents and he lives with
his parents and our car is too small and
it was a tall guy which is this is the
best place we find us it but did you
stand here on the carpet we train right
here I'm gonna top right next to this
tomorrow and I said let's um finish off
and just tell me when you guys are done
so I step outside few minutes later they
finish up they come they leave they're
embarrassed the next day is the best day
because x monday morning we have our
monday full-timers meeting we have about
50 people in the office and I get up and
I spot him he's sitting over here she is
sitting over here okay so I get up I
said oh my gosh I gotta have fun with
this I so listen let me take out
something one of the things that
impresses me the most is when I see
people show up on Sundays to prepare for
their week and let me tell you who
showed up this Sunday to the office to
prepare for the week can we please have
such-and-such stand up and can we have
you stand up he stand up she stands up
there sitting I said listen guys these
guys were here on Sunday strategizing on
what they're going to
to take their business to the next level
I'm so proud of you guys can we give a
round of applause to these guys their
face is so right it's crazy right they
grab a seat
I said I just want you to I'm very proud
of you guys you guys going places so
keep doing what you're doing right now
we're gonna see you at the top
now I've got a really special bonus clip
from Patrick on how to position yourself
properly that I think you're gonna
really enjoy but before that it's time
for the three-point landing questions
time to move from just watching another
video to actually taking action in your
life or your business and if you're
feeling bold leave your answers in the
comments below here we go question
number one what does choosing success
look like to you number two what monster
under your bed do you need to face and
number three what discipline do you need
to develop daily
once you get out of college
once you get out of high school you have
a choice on what you wanted you can go
get a regular job you change your you
trade your work for hours I make fifteen
bucks an hour 20 bucks an hour 30
dollars an hour and that's fine and a
lot of America is just chasing that
there will pay me $16.24
this right and what they don't realize
is that's not how you create wealth
there's got to be an element of you
saying I know for a fact if I position
myself here and if I can become an
entrepreneur or if I can get equity or
if I can get ownership and how do I get
that part this can lead them to
something bigger for myself that's why I
say positioning if you keep trading
hours for a dollar that you're getting
paid you're gonna be limited there's got
to be a part where you go out and
position yourself properly I've set the
story many times I live in wealthy
communities and in these wealthy
communities everybody I talked to I
asked him how did you make your money
you know I made my money because I
started a business great I made my money
because I was part of a startup and
guess what happened to this startup I
was there for five years I ended up
getting piece the company five years
later the company was bought by this
company four billion dollars I got my
six million dollars I've got my $800,000
I got my 2.2 million dollars it's
positioning so wherever you're working
at ask yourself the positioning of the
environment urine is it can't see going
up with there's a possibility for bigger
upside or is it linear hurry up and
change it and if you choose not to
change it then don't be surprised if you
don't have 753 thousand dollars because
you chose the position you're currently
in
[Music]
the most important work ever if you had
to think of one word that's most
important to you or that sums you Apple
that would be like a little beacon if
you want more Patrick check of the tour
that I did of his office in Dallas it
was a lot of fun the link is right there
next to me I think you'll enjoy it
continue to believe and I'll see you
there we're gonna meet Patrick Reed
David today we're gonna explore Dallas
Fort Worth maybe getting some salsa
dancing tonight but first it is time